- Hi, I'm Poppy.
Do you like being famous?
(yelling)
- What the hell's goin' on?
Am I dead?
- You're on a show
inside that person's telephone.
- Hello.
Well, this is new.
That's a pretty, pretty
cellular telephone.
- Do you wanna be more famous?
- Why would I wanna
be more famous?
I'm already really,
really famous.
- All you have to do is say
things people wanna hear,
and then people
will re-tweet you.
- Okay, yeah, I can do that.
Seems easy.
- People like it when you
say chicken sandwich a lot.
- Chicken sandwich.
Chicken sandwich,
mmm, delicious,
delicious chicken sandwiches.
- Chicken sandwich.
- You said chicken sandwich too.
That's great.
- They also like it when
you say delicious sauce.
- I like that.
I'm gonna tweet that now.
- Delicious sauce.
(phone notifications chiming)
- I'm going viral, Poppy!
I'm going viral, Poppy!
I'm going viral!
- Let it flow through
you, Tom Green.
- I feel it inside of me, Poppy!
The throbbing pulse of
the internet flowing
through my veins,
Poppy, through my veins.
- The internet flows
through us all.